foreign
T of rural Iraq is an untapped resource
there is something very special about
this backyard game of pass
the women playing are nationally ranked
athletes
Huda was on the women's indoor football
squad that brought home the 2022 West
Asia cup
her sister Benin plays for one of the
richest clubs in the country proof they
say they are just as capable as men
to me Sports means life I've been
playing football since I was a child I'm
able to play both outdoor and indoor
football but it's difficult because
there are not enough outdoor facilities
for women in Iraq there is no support
from the government with proper training
I am sure all of us women will be able
to play indoor and outdoor football but
if things stay the same then no one will
achieve anything
players and coaches say female athletes
don't get the same Financial or moral
support but their skills are not to be
underestimated
Iraq has a considerable number of good
female players who were skilled and
still young
my advice to the Football Federation is
to pay attention to the abilities and
skills that we have if you want to
achieve victories and want the Iraqi
national team to participate
internationally look after the players
[Music]
women in Iraq are not a monolith
visibility and victories players say
help to change traditional attitudes
and simply to compete is to succeed
it is strange people don't support us
at school even in my neighborhood some
will say you shouldn't leave your house
what's so special about sports but I
don't pay any attention to them I'm
against the idea that it's shameful for
a girl to play football so what we can
play
[Music]
but the challenges are many
some travel five hours just to train for
90 minutes
in subpar facilities that they have to
rent
coaches pay for uniforms and equipment
out of pocket
they should be training almost every day
but huda's Club can only afford to once
a week and unlike richer clubs or male
athletes they don't have sponsors
this is an impressive group but not just
because they rank fourth in the country
their Club can't afford to pay them so
they play purely For the Love of the
Game
they may be indoors and a court may be
smaller than a field but coaches say the
game is Close Quarters relying more on
technique and creativity
so for women accustomed to using brain
over Brawn it is second nature
[Music]
from all over the country from all walks
of life sharing a single passion
snapshot of Iraqi Unity
investing more in women's Athletics they
say means investing in the country's
future
Babylon Iraq